うーむうーむ
[音楽]
こんにちは林その子です
皆さん打つ前ですがベッドボトルのみたが硬くて履かないっていうことをありませんか
そんな時にこの道具があると
スッゴく開けやすくなるんです
ちょっと見ていてください
ね
ほど便利な道具私どうやって手に入れたと思いますか
そう3 d プリンターで作りました
ん
このように女子を音ズレとかして下から上に積み上げていく方式のプリンターが今手に
入りやすいカーです
皆さんの中で
3 d プリンター
言葉を聞いたことがある方はどのぐらいいらっしゃいますでしょうか
ありがとうございますほぼ全ての皆さんがご存知ですね
じゃあ使った事のある方ん
だいぶ少なくなりましたありがとうございます
このように3 d プリンターは名前は聞いたことがあってもまだまだ使って
いらっしゃる方ファッ少ないのが現状です
ところで私の職業はリハビリテーションの専門職です
そして3 d プリンターでこういった道具を作っています
これは握力が弱かったり手や指の関節などに障害があっても
ペットボトルのふたをなくに開けるための道具です
このように障害を持った方の暮らしに役立つ道具を伊波ビリの現場では地上部と言い
ます
私は3 d プリンターで二重を作るワークショップやイベントをしています
去年は作り方の本も出版しました
3 d プリンターで柱上部を作れる人が増えることそして私も3 d ぐインター
使ったことがあります
使えますという方がもっともっと増えることそれが私の願いです
今日は私の話を聞いていただいて皆さんが新しい一緒に作る仲間になってくれるといい
なと思っています
ところで自助具という言葉今日初めて聞きましたという方も多いんじゃないでしょうか
まずは少し自助具とにアピりの話をします
私は3リハビリテーションの職業につい
20年近くになります
皆さんにハビリってどんなイメージをお持ちでしょうか
ウッドや訓練でしょうか
保証したアスリートが復帰のために頑張る姿あたりが馴染みのイメージかも知れません
で
生涯をてから運動や訓練で動きが良くなる方もいます
ですが残念ながら思ったほどには回復されない方もたくさんいます
そんな方にとってその人にぴったり合った自助具があるということはやりたいことが
できることにつながります
私はリハビリとはわー
その人が本当に大切にしている
や言いたいことができるように支えることだと思っています
事情をご存じない方のためにいくつか具体的にご紹介します
これらバージ丈夫ですどんな障害を持った方が何ができるようになるための道部
でしょうか
左の針金が上げてある根元に黄色い持ち手が付いている次女分
こちらは
ボタン a 取っています片手でもボタンをかけやすくするための事情です
指定の部分が温めると柔らかくできる樹脂でできています
使う人の手の大きさや形アプ力に合わせて使いやすく作っています
そしてこちらはソックス a 取っています
手が下とに届かない方でも靴下を履けるようになるため後ジョブです
使う人の足の大きさや履きたい靴下の種類に合わせて作りしています
このように
即制度に2したをセットして
足を入れていきます
引っ張り上げて
はい励ました
こんな風にリハビリの現場では日々変化する一人一人の体に合わせて細かく道具を作っ
てきました
でも今徐々に動画を作らなくなってきています
社会の高齢化が進み様々な企業が介護やすくシミサービスを提供するようになった結果
今では福祉用具や道具は販売されているものやねんたるできるものを
カタログの中から選ぶことが主流になってきています
でも実際には
カタログの中に一人一人のグラシア体にぴったり合った道具がないこともあります
するとせっかくその人がやりたいことや暮らしたい生活があってもカタログに道具が
なければ諦めなくてはいけないということになってしまわないでしょうか
私は何かいい方法がないかなあと打つと悩んでいました
道具が販売されていないからやりたいことをあきらめ
でもその私の悩みを解消してくれたものがありました
それが3 d プリンターです
3 d プリンターは一人一人に合わせたものづくりが得意です
今世界中で爆発的に3 d プリンターを活用する人が増えています
3 d プリンターはデジタル化されたデータからものを作ります
なので物の形をデータにして保存したり共有することができます
3 d モデルのシェアサイトというものがあります
3 d のモデルがデータとして世界中で共有されています
商売を持つ方の暮らしに役立つ道具のモデルもたくさんシェアされています
ここから無料でデータを手に入れて3 d プリンターで作ることができます
こちらはアメリカの方がシェアしているボタンをかけるため後ジョブのモデルと私が
シェアしている
靴下を履くための柱上部の持てるです
このように3 d プリンターを使うと
既存の自助具が立体にしてそしてデータとして共有することができます
既存にある道具の形だけでなく既存のんになり動画の形も皆さんのアイデアを活かして
道具にできる可能性があります
そしてモデルのアレンジも簡単にできます
こちらはスプーンを持つ方が持つことが難しい方が使う4分フォルダーです
共有モデルをアレンジして一人ひとりに合った形にすることができます
必要な道具の形をあきらめなくていい
体の状態がどのようになってもその状態にあった道具を手に入れることができれば
やりたいことをあきらめなくていいんです
そしてデータは世界中で共有されています
ロード4歳すれば使いたい人が使いたい時に本当に必要なものを自分たちの手で作る
ことができます
例えば世界の端から端まででも燃料を使って商品を運ぶ必要がありません
環境にも良さそうです
だから私たちは作った次女部のモデルをたくさんシェアしています
もうシェアしているモデルは150を超えています
誰でもデータを無料で手に入れることができます
でもデータだけ無料で手に入っても3 d プリンターや材料のコストってどれくらい
なんだろうって思ってらっしゃる方もいらっしゃいますよね
失敗入りません3 d プリンター今やすいんです
私は3万円前後の3 d プリンターでほとんどの子ジョブを作っています
ソフトも無料のものを使っています
材料も高くありません
硬いも度から柔らかいもの金属っぽいものから
あたがメルト柔らかくして形を変えれる材料までいろんな種類があります
私は1キログラム当たり3000前後の材料を使うことが多いです
例えばこれぐらいの大きさの柱上部でしたら
材料費は50円くらいです
そして3 d プリンターはものづくりへのハードル
障害をなくすこともできます
簡単なマウスと酒井できれば誰でもものづくりに参加することができるんです
中央の車いすに座っている彼腫れは脳性まひで重度の運動障害があります
腕の可動域もわずかです
でも動かすことのできる左でを上手く使って
トラックボールのマウスでモデルを作ること
モデリングができます
彼のつけているヘッド版とその先に棒状なものが伸びています
あれは実は彼自身がんモデリングしたパソコンのキーボードを打つための自助部です
そして彼はこのスキルと道具を使って誰か別の人の望みを叶えることもできるんです
こちらの動画はある障がいを持った女の子の
重ならずに文字が書けるようになりたいという願いを叶えるためのモデルを
あれが作ったものです
左上が道具を使う前
中央がー道具を使ってあれがあの所が入ってくれたメッセージです
このように技術の力を使えば障害があっても自分自身の暮らしをより便利で楽しくする
とうづくりに参加することができますそしてさらには他の誰かの暮らしをより良くする
ことにも参加することができるんです
私たちはこんな3 d プリンターの力を最大限に活かした道具作りのイベントをやっ
ています
障害を持った方やその支援ションチームメンバーに加え
その人が本当に必要な道具作りを3 d プリンターなども活用しながら短期間集中し
て行うイベントです
スプールのメイクとマラソンのを掛け合わせてメーカーソンっていいます
私たちのメーカー村では障害を持った方や支援者を
need を知る人にーどんなおーわーと呼びます
まずは need no わぁの話をよ多く聞きます
その道具があってそれが出来るようになる彼とはその方にとってどんな価値があるのか
をチーム内で共有する時間を十分に取ります
チーマーなるべく多様な背景やスキルを持った仲間と結成します
そしてアイデアやデザインをみんなで一緒に考えます
そしてその場で3 d プリンターなどで8にしていきます
そしてさらにその場で使う人が試して使ってみます
時間内に試作を繰り返します
最後は成果を皆で共有していきます
イベントの途中で制作プロセスとデータをインターネット上で公開していきます
最終的にはもっとたくさんの世界中の方が見てそして発揚していただけるよう
グローバルなネットワークで一平たを公開します
これが私たちのメーカー村です
ここで私たちのメーカー村の成果を一つご紹介します
今日みなさんにご紹介するのは als の患者さん江村さんのチームの成果です
als 筋萎縮性側索硬化症は全身の筋肉が徐々に減少し力がなくなっていく新報性の
病気です
えグラサンはこの時移動は車椅子
両手の力特に左手の力が減少し
を一人では紙パックの飲み物の蓋を開けることができない状況でした
でも江村さんはお一人のときでも自分で好きな時に飲み物を出して好きなタイミングで
決定のみたい
そんな願いを叶えるための道具ず便にこのチームは挑戦しました
紙バッグに差し込んでいる白い三角すいのモデルがこのジウンの成果です
作は見事成功しました
皆さんが挙げた飲み物でチームでカンパーイ
この道具は症状が進行し続ける als の患者さんにとって必要な期間はとても限ら
れているかもしれません
この道具は商品化するほど数の需要があるものではないかもしれません
この need はこれまでは諦めることが当たり前だったに良いのかもしれません
でも3 d プリンターがあればほど need はあきらめなくていいんです
そして限られたに井戸でも世界中にはきっと今その道具を必要としている人がたくさん
います
だから私たちは作った道具のデータをたくさんインターネット上でシェアしています
世界中で同じ取り組みが広がっています私たちは世界の仲間と
モデルの共有を始めています
このメーカー村は障害があっても高齢になっても誰でも笑顔で暮らせるために
道具のデータを共有しでき共有するチャレンジです
障害のないピーターの参加しさんもたくさんいます
そしてこんな風におっしゃってくださいます
この命こそに来ると自分のスキルが役立ってそして目の前で誰かもできなかったことが
できるようになって
一緒に感動して喜び合える
こんなばは他にはないんです
障害のある人もない人もみんなで力を合わせ世界の誰かもっと笑顔にするということを
共通の目標に
一緒に動画作りをする場です
ぜひ皆さんも一緒に作るな代わりになりにいらしてください
ものづくりのスキルは問いません
皆さんの周囲の方あるよ皆さん自身が将来
障害やカレーが理由で暮らしにご負担を抱えるかもしれません
できないことが増えていく
我慢を強いられることが増えていく
でも諦めなくていいです
我慢しなくていいんです
諦めてしまったら
世界中のみんなが諦めたくてはいけないかもしれません
この取り組みは今始めばきっと
一人ひとりにぴったり合った次女部のモデルが共有されそして誰でも手に入れることが
できる
そんな世の中をつくるための第一歩になります
でも今始めなければ
そんな道具を手に入れることが出来る人と出来ない人の格差は拡大していく一方だと私
は思っています
すべての混乱は社会の財産にすることができます
なので今目の前にある混乱を解決するための道具を作ってみましょう
そしてデータにして共有しましょう
ひとりでできなければみんなで作りましょう
そしてみんなで
世界の明るい未来を創っていきましょう
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]